Alright, so let me try to, to write that down in a, in a way that let's us
summarize it. So I think what you're trying to
say is when we did that one dimensional case,
it had, the b c dimension was one. When we did the interval, it was two. When we
did two dimensional, lineal separator, it was three. And
you're wondering whether in, three dimensions, it would be four.
>> Yes.
>> So that's, yeah, a really good insight. Let me, be a little
bit more precise here. That the hypothesis spaces in each of these cases
here, they, they were defined this parameter theta. In
the interval case it was defined by a and b.
In the two dimensional case it was defined by
w and theta, and w was in two dimensions so
this was actually, a vector of size two. So,
yeah, each time we went up, it, to do a
different example, we actually added another parameter. And, it
looks like the bc dimension is the number of parameters.
>> Hm.
>> So
in a sense it's it's the dimensionality of the
space in which the hypotheses live. So it really,
it really fits very nicely. That doesn't exactly answer
your question. It is the case that for a three
dimensional problem there's going to be four dimensions. And so
it turns out you are right. That for any d
dimensional hyperplane concept class or hypothesis class, the vc
dimension is going to end up being d plus 1.
>> Oh, I see, and that's because
the number of parameters that you need to represent
a d dimensional hyperplane is in fact, d plus 1.
>> That's right. Yeah, d, the weights for each of the dimensions
plus the theta, you know, the greater than or equal to thing.